des prairies asséché pas d'herbe pour
nourrir les vaches les éleveurs sont
obligés depuis plusieurs semaines de
puiser dans les stocks de nourriture
réservée habituellement pour l'hiver
c'est le cas de jean edouard
avec ses quelque 170 bête il estime ses
pertes à près de 50000 euros sur son
chiffre d'affaires depuis le début de
l'année les vaches ont plus rien à
manger dans les prairies donc on est
déjà au rythme des alimentations d'hiver
c'est à dire peu plus d'une tonne une
teinte 5 2 fois par jour
donc on a récolté moins en première
coupe parce que il y avait la sécheresse
donc on a récolté au moins 30% à 40% de
moins et on est déjà en train d'utiliser
cette première coupe pour nourrir
maintenant depuis le début de l'été le
déficit fourrager s'élève à plus de 2
millions 700 mille euros selon la
chambre d'agriculture
un comité de sécheresse tire les
conséquences et une vraie préoccupation
donc on va travailler en lien avec la
chambre d'agriculture
et puis les partenaires agricoles sur
l'opportunité ou pas de classer en
calamité agricole une partie du
territoire où tout le territoire
d'eure-et-loir et des financièrement les
éleveurs qui ont subi des pertes
occasionnées par des événements
climatiques c'est l'objectif du
dispositif des calamités agricoles
si pour le syndicat fdsea la mesure
devrait être efficace pour d'autres elle
a ses limites
on sait que depuis quelques temps la
procédure de calamité s'est énormément
complexifier pour les agriculteurs donc
c'est un dossier de plus à remplir pour
des aides qui vont être finalement par
la hauteur de la catastrophe
il faudra attendre la fin de l'année
2015 pour que ces aides soient
débloquées
si le dispositif est déclenché